[Musique]
ce n'est pas tous les jours qu'un
concert commence avec des champs
traditionnels des temples bouddhistes
qui laissent ensuite la place à
l'agressivité de la musique d'être métal
[Applaudissements]
coffre dormant groupe taïwanais mené par
un chanteur originaire de la
Saskatchewan Music
les sutras bouddhistes des écrits
traditionnels forment la base de chacune
des chansons
[Musique]
réelles soeur bouddhiste et fan de cette
musique d’être métal miaou ben assure le
côté cérémonial sur scène
plus nous devons répandre notre message
unique de compassion
si les membres du groupe formés il y a 4
ans sont adeptes du bouddhisme ce n'est
pas le cas de tous les fans
cherche pas à les convertir mais plutôt
à les aider à trouver leur propre voix
vers le bien-être
pour le chanteur canadien cette aventure
représente le chemin vers la santé
mentale l'idée de former le groupe lui a
été proposé alors qu'il était en
profonde dépression en proie a des idées
suicidaires
aujourd'hui il savoure chaque journée et
chaque concert la transformation du
karma c'est le vœu que fait le groupe
d'ArmA pour ses admirateurs
[Musique]
il suffit Leblanc Radio-Canada